achei a música boyzone boa noite
obrigado pelo convite meu nome é cláudio
houve dois países
meu pai era segredo minha mãe era
costureira e então alguém todo dia tem
que construir as casas têm que fazer as
roupas a brinquedos nazi
nada disso me por essa pessoa que pareça
e usa roupas doadas à noite numa empresa
rosa periferia na cidade não seria da
mesma natureza
a minha pobreza minha maior que as
provas que mesmo assim não é bom jesus
na vila de trabalhadores continuavam a 0
todos e fugiram com brasileiros mostrou
a vontade minha mãe para igualdade
tive uma infância bem legal 13 anos que
mora na nossa filha aqui há lugar mais
longe o temor aos 12 anos eu morava em 6
900 mil moradores
mas quando eu tinha 13 anos só quero
ganhar meu futebol namorada por certo a
via não tinha nada tinha mapa
agora falta
a razão público tinham esquerda e 17
anos - acredito mas é um dos cotados
ele mora na comunidade pronto porque não
tinha nada tinha o formato curvo acaba e
eu dizia maioria a melhorar
transformação da angus 25 anos eu tive a
oportunidade de sair pelo brasil
reconheceria de morar com um pouco tem
algo mais rápidos o bastante
o brasil no gama na periferia de versões
de perseguição de fahel
o são paulo então eu gostava muito de
gosta da metrópole assim na última
estação que já havia mais companhias a
pra mim o povo
amo corpo a agora neste exato momento
nós sabemos dos matemáticos físicos
planeta já 400 mil anos por hora pela
classe
nós estamos aqui conversando é aguardar
quase tão mais essa coisa de fazer parte
do planeta coisa de criança então uma
típica fazia parte saiba não conseguiam
ver essas fronteiras geográficas cultura
assim você não tem quando eu voltei a
sociais que o brasil nosso país e nosso
povo
eu tenho a minha comunidade como é
voltar a trabalhar porque lá houve
também a seguir
graças a deus meus problemas sobretudo
saneamento e chiado
assim asfalto na rua 40 anos avançando
barco - o goleiro não é fácil a estima
vai lá embaixo a comunidade se joga mais
na política toma conta das associações a
esse propósito por troca com orson
welles comentários em baixo de futebol
está com gosto rede com bola o sport
aberto não só com saúde é bom e esgoto é
escolher o coletiva para pedir coisas
assim
explore a 15 anos nós tínhamos o lixão
mas pela minha casa e era um terreno que
eu vi aqui imagine eu tirar o empate
tirar o ano que terá a copa da
prefeitura que a gente fazia a retirada
dos invasores
além de ser um lixão não dava meus
bichos mortos fora já o lixo doméstico e
aí eu descanse vem a conta da prefeitura
em particular na área durante um ato com
reservas ou caminhos é que depois do
ataque o condomínio não prefeitura fazer
essa pesquisa é descobrir que a história
é um projeto de brasil desde 1962
anda assim 60 saem tão legal a
prefeitura protocolou um pedido para
equipamentos prazo que não existia só
umas esquerdas elas são paulo um ano e
nada temo que na mídia fazer um grande
ano para julho e depois lançou a coleção
de limpeza da praça
muito legal que as melhorias não tem
área de lazer muito pouco a fazer isso
também eu descobri depois eu tenha
trabalhado aqui no monte serrat da gente
eu soube toa e chegou a defender a minha
morte no dia 30 em casa de volta ao
resultado com outras coisas erradas no
estágio estão atrás dessas crianças do
natação empresa comemora os gols da
mesma quadra
não vamos fazer então há 15 anos esse
chão pois não abraça e depois foi embora
na selva fechada de forma como o
importante foi melhorando
hum a gente olhava a mochila nova chega
a uma canção apenas de defesa
consideraram uma partida somente com ela
longo é muito bom dia você tem mais
piada era santa casa e beneficência
agora chega sendo partilha via dia ela
também de cada chave ela é uma
referência de bondade e de saúde são
todos procuravam hoje em cinema é que
também nos 50m onde estão os livros
nós conquistamos um livro ilustrado
colocar o nome na praça de machico vamos
à luta também que nos prometeram depois
que a qimonda esteve na câmera ligada
com ele
hoje a prefeitura na praça maria da
silva já começou a fazer essa diferença
em homenagem a essa senhora que estava
com o nome dele só que é a minha forma
mas aí a criança ainda estava na rua
é um projeto que vai trabalhar para a
comunidade sabe de alguma forma sempre
morei no colégio 17 anos aconteceu paga
mais separar e eu não queria ficar num
encontro à nossa e tal situação eu vou
morar no colégio bate um bom ponto eles
colocaram as formas fontes
para ele as peças chaves
moraes e forte para descontar isso na
minha frente ampla não foi como eu
queria
então criamos o projeto chega no início
era só recreativo jogava futebol tão
fácil da vovó uma medalha mas também
dava muita briga futebol da banda até
hoje da praia né
então você vai ter que ser agora
cultural
então há dez anos e ter sido natural mas
temos um espaço fundamental casa
nós não temos dinheiro não temos que ver
o suporte às vendas só valência foi a
nova saída caso você você achar casa vai
ter por rede social não há cinco anos
possui um boneco de olinda que
representava xix e pouco nesta cidade
trabalhar com todos puderam então a moça
chega bem 11 2107 ano
ela faleceu em 83 suas 30 anos depois
ela voltou à vida enquanto penso ai meu
deus ele a comunidade
e aí é só me mais mudança coisas têm um
espaço cultural suportável que oferece
iniciação a valer para 2011 finanças
nós temos computadores de todos os 43
feira 4 pode estar que foi nossas
páginas do nosso blog
nós criamos uma pequena biblioteca nós
temos campanhas nos anos da rede social
da campanha ajuda de doença com esta
campanha a prova
com uma tal fato de é quase quinze reais
o pacote está a pobreza mas a doença não
é fácil porque as famílias não transitem
pessoas planeja treinar eu tenho que
ficar até hoje proteger tanto o zé
gotinha ontem 10 porque estou me acorda
eu tenho uma coisa pra ele né não
contribuir tem um enteado é que a
criança tenha dado a você algumas há
quatro anos
assim ela passou pela rua crianças na
minha rua e ela já tinha uma semana a
escola já começar o ano letivo é um
mesmo boletim que o outro não tem
material ainda vai receber o pai sócio
ambiental destacou essa cambada também
já não é muita gente inclusive está
acusando as duas formas
a campanha na rede social e pela rede
social
a linha vila safira uma vila nova lado
falava mãe que também não tinha um
cheiro de esgoto não tinha música
continuação não tinha ônibus foram os
mais sujos passava montado ao ver o
nosso senhor
quando via um ano esperam a passagem
estava com alguns amigos para passar o
meu sonho eles embora foi pegar uma bola
então nós fizemos a campanha na rede
social que gosta muito fácil acompanhar
uma baleia orca e que também não tinha
nessa copa troller deus e agora está sob
a guarda da criança na rua sabe com as
avós e não pela nova lei é uma
transformação foi acontecendo
a campanha do material escolar nós
estamos no quarto ano esse ano
no primeiro ano a gente filma dez colada
140 delas foi em vão afinal nunca tinha
feito
ninguém é conhecer a comunidade que não
tinha prática
agora a média de visitas de 300 a 400
pessoas por ano dinheiro do teatro vai
garantir que todos são bem-vindos abert
não tem estação
todos vão nos ajudar a nos conhecer a
história o xinga ela nosso legado
palestrante do teste seder de dados da
história da china que mostrou o
contrário
felicidade pode ser poderosa e até mesmo
terminar essa história é sempre olha
aqui seu primeiro ano
segundo anos eu vou fazer de novo só que
eu fazia campanha em janeiro e fevereiro
o pessoal da praia do canto mas
conseguimos segundo ano 160 que
existência do bloco do número que
trabalhou no nome do terceiro ano
comecei a fazer a campanha como natal do
futuro empregado natal com mais
arrecadação então você fazer muita
amizade da rede social com jornalistas
de todos os veículos porque tudo que eu
ia ficar assim houve a gente é muito
transparente de 1199 espera passar ou
não se a pessoa não poderia mais deixar
que eu faço questão uma criança eu faça
a entrega registro concluiu o técnico
muitas pessoas comprometidas com a
transparência
então neste terceiro ano foi fundamental
do futuro
nós avançamos 700 mil
aí conseguimos esse ano o padrinho da
campanha como alex o jogador ainda em
uma época bastava um toque de recolher
não estava fácil
foi muito legal para a gente fina é
concursado clubística é a pessoa 60 e ao
conselho a criança falou com as crianças
existiu a nossa camiseta fotografando a
boa campanha
ele vestiu nossa camisa 11 da manhã no
programa de tv e em favor da campanha e
eu estou muito não se sabe dizer se
rádio mandou um caminhão
não não é essa a nossa é essa proposta
com ele e que a pessoa a imagem é isso
foi legal bem material escolar de santa
catarina de pessoas disseram eu vi o
alex fazendo um vídeo e olha que legal
né
lançado como vem de um gremista deu
sobrevida mas o alex ouve um vídeo maíra
olha só que tal cansou e aí a sian
ansiosamente mil à campanha da cidade
estamos plantando sementes já existe em
outros bairros com os parceiros a base
também começa então começamos a campanha
então a gente quer passar esse exemplo
de atitude de não esperar que em geral
pode fazer o que sabe fazer
na minha comunidade não tem placa com o
nome de rua a gente sabe a dificuldade
que é uma cidade né
se acha uma placa nós começamos a fazer
as placas e colocando a esquina e foi
notícia seria só então sempre uma coisa
tão simples
então gostei um boneco de machico boneco
eo agir no dia que saiu porque ele foi
até a família da china uma em frente à
mina na minha casa
assim andrade 91 história que eu
conhecia
13 anos como ela tinha sim eu fui uma
das crianças do cabo por ela porque eu
freqüentava a casa dela ela não estava
nessas do documento farmácia no caso e
que a gente acredita em faculdades
então nós já fomos ao rio são paulo leva
ao desgaste e minas são paulo e turismo
está uma ontem levando essa história da
marina sai andando por aí valeu a correr
tão bem aqui e aquele pessoal da saúde
pessoal ele tem mesmo aquele que fala
inglês a igreja tinha empresário a china
chegaram porque a gente usa que uma
identificação se sabe para facilitar é
preso nesta manhã com nego ela não
representa um ano
então nós conquistamos o asfaltamento de
parte da rua
nós conquistamos gostar mais de 100
família sensi ele pode impedir quieto
nós temos a tv machida no youtube se
escolhe uma pesquisada que são
estudantes de jornalismo seguinte a
oferecer é pra fazer essa tv mostrando
nosso programa
nós temos o livro da planta na história
da china vai lançar um livro didático
nas escolas junto com o nome se na
página do lado de uma banda toca em são
paulo uma mulher prova chega só nessa
altura a maior cidade da américa latina
a história da minha rua natura nem
conhecia e hoje nós somos parceiros das
três fora do bairro
nós somos parceiros que a doação de
roupas da igreja católica tinha que ter
um plano
é uma opinião é explodir sabe a minha
parte como página
nós somos todos os vizinhos não consigo
ver ao certo o motivo não vai ser eu a
gente não gosta da gente aquela coisa
sabe que sempre foi discreto conceito
ela dizendo que era sempre de vidas
então ano passado apareceu ligado a um
videogame internacional era só quem
trabalha pra globo e ele só quer fazer
um vídeo da mochila e assim tem sido a
nossa vida sabe as pessoas têm para
fazer um livro continha o rio sabe a
venda do livro é pra eles mas eu tenho
uma história que eu possa mostrar as
pessoas não tomam o fato de usar o
dinheiro entregue é como diz a doutora
bom nome
ele compra a matéria a gente não
trabalha com madeira de qualidade à
vontade passa o sentimento então ele fez
um vídeo lendo magnífico de um minuto e
meio que contestou a nossa comunidade
estou muito feliz por causa dessa ilha
agora chegou a correr mais um vídeo em
que um casal cineasta veio domingo junto
foi convidado pelos caçadores de bons
exemplos e se conhecem é um casal que
viaja o brasil
11 anos e ele também criamos resulta ea
convite do casal é arriscado auxiliar
jurídico do sindipetróleo gravar com a
gente agora virou um dever t&d funciona
num canal futura e assim precisar eu
tenho programas eu tenho visto do a
faculdade sabe falar do nosso trabalho
de atitude
estou muito feliz por isso já a deus por
estar aqui nossa escola e deixa duas
vezes então
eu vou fazer porque é um só a roche
cameos avó quando os medos em trajetos
de traziam nada apenas escolas na lógica
eu acho que você incendiado e uma
carteira com o dinheiro da comunidade
não iríamos na escola nem time viveu se
um dia você saúde onde o médico então a
fazer o usuário identificar achava ela
como se fosse uma média e conquistar
contávamos histórias acamar não acho que
é uma grandiosa ganhou são pessoas que
não têm uma história da cultura negra
resgatar essa história infelizmente nós
não temos os livros então diria resgatar
essa história de bombagem de água tinham
espaço cultural oferecendo às crianças
elevada estima da comunidade são essas
idéias são os básicos na força na forma
de trazê los à força
aqui na rede social naquele primeiro ano
conseguiu prendê-los falava 140 crianças
uma das histórias que move é transformar
essa em dança aí eu vejo a dora então
alegria longe dela saindo então
conseguiu transformar se no chão uma
praça nos conseguimos colocar a história
da mochila no rio e didática e
transpô-la chega faz parte da história
do brasil como nena a gente não está
enviando um partido político a gente não
tem dinheiro a gente não é um ente não
quer ser um bom dirigente trabalho
voluntário como fazer o chip